Speaker 1: So we have another new headline
about the spending bill slash infrastructure
bill discussion that continues to I don't want to
be negative, but it sort of is like plaguing us
at this point. The fact that this discussion and
grandstanding and people getting attention for
getting getting attention, for opposing
things that they should be in favor of.
But maybe this is good news and the news is that
House Democrats have put paid family leave back
into the spending bill. Now I'm going to tell
you what the news is, and I'm going to tell you
what's being said. But my view on this is that
this in and of itself may be grandstanding,
and I don't know if I'm at this point, just
jaded and cynical. You'll have to tell me,
but we'll get to that. Remember, the context is
that even as things were completely falling apart,
Bernie Sanders went on TV over the weekend and
said, Hey, I'm still working on the prescription
drug cost control aspect of this. And then on
Tuesday, it was announced, Hey, the prescription
drug control component is back in the bill.
We talked about that a couple of days ago.
Now the news is House Democrats put paid family
leave back into the bill. The Hill reporting House
Democrats have amended the enormous social
spending framework at the heart of President
Biden's economic agenda to include paid family
leave, a popular provision that had met resistance
from Senator Joe Manchin and was thought to
be removed. The change was announced Wednesday
morning in a letter from Speaker Pelosi, who said
the House Rules Committee would meet later in the
day to consider the changes. But Pelosi stopped
short of announcing the vote on the package.
Instead, the speaker said there
remain a few outstanding issues.
It has been my intention through the process to
put on the House floor and pass a bill that would
pass the Senate in the same form because I've been
informed by a senator of opposition to a few of
the priorities contained in our bill, and because
we must have legislation agreed to by the House
and Senate in the final version of Build Back
Better that will we will send to the president's
desk. We must strive to find common ground. Biden
initially proposed 12 weeks of paid family leave,
a provision adopted by House Democrats, but
Manchin balked at the 490 $4 billion price tag,
forcing negotiators to consider a sharp reduction
down to four weeks before Biden slashed it
altogether. Progressives grumbled and said they
would accept that they would accept it as a cost
of enacting other social benefits. Pelosi on
Wednesday, however, said paid leave would be
part of the House Rules Committee discussion.
The decision came at the urging of many members
of the cost conscious caucus. Chairman Richie
Neal and the committee staff have worked on
this priority for a long time and were ready. The
provision will provide for weeks not the 12 four
weeks of permanent parental and medical leave,
according to an aide familiar with the language.
Alex Bolton reporting mansion, not thrilled to
hear Speaker Pelosi has added four weeks of paid
leave back in BBB. That's a challenge and they
know how I feel about it. So, OK, first of all,
this isn't the infrastructure bill. This is the
2022 budget bill labeled Build Back Better or BBB.
There's confusion between the two. Without a
doubt. Often it's not really. They just say
the bill. So there's confusion, but this is the
build back better bill. Now, in an ideal world,
everything would be in its own bill. So you say,
OK, let's do a bill for paid family leave. Who's
for it? Who's against it? OK, you figure it
out. The problem is that if you did that,
a whole bunch of stuff would just never pass.
The whole system we have is this pseudo corrupt
system of cronyism and earmarks and pork where
people in the House and Senate agree to support X
as long as Y is in there. And that's sort of like
a for better or for worse thing. That's why we
get these packages with so many things in there.
Now there are real questions as to how these four
weeks would even work. Do you have to pay into
it or not? What counts is leave. What's a worker?
What about gig workers? What about self-employed
people, independent contractors? Does it only
apply to W-2? We just don't know. And what's
the future of this? We have absolutely no idea.
What I know is two things, and this is where
I want to go back to. Am I being too cynical?
Time is running out to get this done this calendar
year to get this done before the House and Senate
recess for the end of the year. I am starting to
wonder whether things are getting added back in
so that it looks better as a bill that's
not going to pass. What I mean by that is
one perspective is that build back better is
that the build back better act, at least in 2021,
is not going to pass. So thinking very
cynically, are they making the bill more
robust so that when it doesn't pass, they can
say, Look, we, we put our best foot forward.
We added prescription drug controls. We added
some paid leave so that the bill looks better to
progressives knowing that the bill is essentially
dead. They will not pass a better bill.
Rather than not pass a crappier bill.
I don't know. It's all disappointing.
This has been going on for months at this
point. These are all things that should
not be controversial in a country as rich as the
United States. These things aren't controversial
in most other countries that are level of wealth.
But don't me know if you think I'm being too
cynical about now, they're just trying to make
the bill better before not passing it to say
it would have been a pretty good bill, but it has
no chance of passing. Let me know what you think.